this is really the tough stuff anyone
can spend more money anyone can announce
tax cuts but I think for the Tory right
my free market friends they've really
got to ask questions about spending and
they've really got to be bold about
spending and restrained and I think
that's something that we missed last
year certainly the markets I mean Liz
has said oh well we it was all fully
costed it wasn't well certainly the
markets didn't believe that the people
examining that and they didn't believe
that so I think we got to be credible
about that and you know an excuse for
the last few years we did have a covid
global pandemic which actually was the
one thing that blew apart any kind of
spending restraint because we spent
something like 300 billion in one year
on the covid support now we can argue
whether that was the right thing or the
wrong thing but that's what happened and
much of the debate around public
spending now certainly in the 2020s has
been driven by what happened in terms of
the co intervention